[Música]
estoy seguro de que la gran mayoría de
vosotros habéis escuchado eso de que la
Iglesia Católica está de capa caída que
es muy arcaica que se ha quedado fuera
de juego y que el islam está comiendo
terreno en todo el mundo y bueno no
podemos decir que esto sea del todo
falso en el caso por ejemplo de Europa y
históricamente el gran bastión de esta
religión sí es verdad el catolicismo
sigue siendo muy importante en el viejo
continente no hay más que echar un
vistazo a este mapa como podéis ver en
países como Polonia o Croacia más del
80% de su población se considera
Católica y en países como Italia España
o Francia este porcentaje supera el 60%
claro que luego el porcentaje de
católicos practicantes es mucho más
pequeño en España por ejemplo hablamos
de menos del 19% de la población pero
sea como sea Europa ya no es el
epicentro del catolicismo con el aumento
de la población mundial este continente
ha pasado de albergar en torno a las dos
terceras partes de toda la población
católica del mundo en 19 10 a sólo el
25% 100 años después y está queridos
amigos es una tendencia que no parece
que vaya a parar fijaos por ejemplo en
esta gráfica
[Música]
en España uno de los países
históricamente más católicos de Europa
la tendencia es muy clara Cuanto más
jóvenes menos creyentes pero ojo esto
ocurre no solo entre los católicos
ocurre también con el resto de
confesiones religiosas pero sea como sea
por este motivo no nos puede extrañar
que claro la santa sede este preocupada
por el futuro del catolicismo en Europa
y por supuesto también en el resto del
mundo sí se quedan infieles ya no tendrá
razón de ser en términos empresariales
tendrá que echar abajo La persiana ojo
un apunte estamos en visualpolitik este
no es un vídeo sobre La Fe Ni para bien
ni para mal Nuestro objetivo pasa por
analizar lo que está ocurriendo con una
de las religiones más importantes del
mundo indagar en su futuro y descubrir
que repercusiones políticas pueden tener
todos estos cambios
[Música]
dicho esto y como curiosidad nunca
confundáis a la santa sede con la ciudad
del Vaticano ya os hemos explicado
alguna vez la diferencia entre ambos
conceptos en este canal Es algo que se
podría resumir tal que así la expresión
Santa sede se refiere al conjunto
constituido por la autoridad la
jurisdicción y la soberanía conferidas
al papa y a sus Sucesores para dirigir
la Iglesia Católica en todo el mundo
Sara Susana pozos Bravo doctora en
relaciones internacionales Unión Europea
y globalización por la universidad
complutense de Madrid y la ciudad del
Vaticano es básicamente un estado que se
creó en 1929 para darle una identidad
territorial a la santa sede lo que
además la ha facilitado pues establecer
relaciones con otros países y estar
presente en organizaciones
internacionales como la propia ONU y
algunos os estaréis preguntando Pero
quién manda aquí vale es cierto el papá
es la cabeza de la santa sede y por eso
también lo es del Vaticano y de la
Iglesia Católica pero creéis que el solo
puede dirigir todo el cotarro en
absoluto por eso se apoya tanto en el
servicio Civil del pontificado como en
la famosa curia romana y qué es esto que
suena tan elegante en resumen un
conjunto de congregaciones tribunales
pontificios consejos y lo más importante
de todo la secretaría de estado la
secretaría de estado es absolutamente
crucial para la imagen y las relaciones
de la santa sede con el resto del mundo
porque es el organismo que se encarga
básicamente de su política exterior y en
un momento en el que la iglesia católica
no parece atravesar su mejor momento el
papá va a necesitar un secretario de
estado fuerte por eso cabe hacernos
algunas preguntas qué está haciendo el
Vaticano para recuperar la influencia de
la santa sede en el mundo Qué futuro
tiene el catolicismo qué ocurre con la
famosa diplomacia vaticana es posible
que Europa esté siendo sustituida por
otra región como auténtico epicentro y
motor de la iglesia de Pedro queridos
amigos amigas hoy vamos a responder a
todas estas preguntas pero antes antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
la madre de todas las diplomacias
qué país creéis que fue el primero en
tejer una auténtica política diplomática
estoy seguro de que muchos estaréis
pensando en algún país europeo como
España o Francia o quizás Inglaterra O
tal vez Incluso en alguna histórica
potencia asiática como china pues craso
error la diplomacia moderna no comenzó
con ningún estado sino con la propia
Santa sede para que os hagáis una idea
se estima que empezó a mantener
relaciones diplomáticas entre los siglos
cuarto y quinto y no solo eso sabéis
Quién fundó la primera escuela
diplomática de todo el mundo Exacto
también fue la santa sede Pero esta vez
un poco más tarde en el año 1701 es
decir que cuando hablamos de la santa
sede no solo hablamos de la Iglesia
También de un histórico y poderoso
aparato político no obstante lo de la
santa sede y su influencia en el resto
del mundo no ha sido un camino
precisamente de rosas y eso a pesar de
su larga y extendida experiencia desde
luego ha habido momentos para el olvido
[Música]
ya fuera por el Concilio de iniciar
primero en el 325 después de Cristo o
por la presencia de apoquirisarios
acreditados de la santa sede en la corte
Imperial de bizancio en el 453 después
de Cristo la diplomacia de la santa sede
es considerada no solo la más antigua
del mundo sino también una de las más
poderosas e influyentes no obstante el
poder de los papás y de la santa sede ha
sufrido varios golpes desde la paz de
wesfalia de 1648 que le otorgó un poder
mayor a los Estados nación europeos y a
Los Monarcas pasando por el desprecio a
los poderes del Papa por parte de
Napoleón Bonaparte y llegando a la
disolución de los estados pontificios en
1870 la iglesia católica ha llegado a
estar verdaderamente contra las cuerdas
ante el avance del poder de los estados
modernos a esto además se le unen las
críticas por su inacción en momentos
clave limitándose muchas ocasiones a
lanzar solo declaraciones condenatorias
fue algo que se denunció durante la
primera y segunda guerra mundial y
también ahora durante la Guerra de
Ucrania sin embargo también ha recibido
grandes elogios por ejemplo por su papel
en el fin de la Guerra Fría durante el
papado de Juan Pablo II
vamos que como os decía el camino de la
santa sede no ha sido un camino de rosas
que digamos pero aún así han logrado
establecer vínculos con la inmensa mayor
parte de los países del Mundo
De hecho son tantos los países en los
que hay anuncios los diplomáticos del
Vaticano que nos resultaron mucho más
fácil señalar a los 12 países con los
que no tienen relaciones diplomáticas
establecidas tanto por ser estos países
musulmanes como comunistas Y es que aquí
Tenemos que tener en cuenta que la santa
sede parte con una ventaja muy pero que
muy importante su diplomacia se basa
sobre todo en sus redes de ayuda ya sea
construyendo hospitales como escuelas o
comedores sociales la Iglesia Católica
muchas veces sustituye lo que
habitualmente son responsabilidades del
Estado especialmente Claro está en los
países más Pobres y eso eso es algo que
suele traducirse mucha pero que mucha
influencia social por ejemplo en la
capital de burkina faso encontramos el
centro educativo Santa Vicente María que
proporciona educación a más de 400
chicas jóvenes sin recursos otro ejemplo
lo podemos encontrar en turcana Kenia
donde han construido escuelas
preescolares y además de programas de
ayuda a enfermos ancianos y
discapacitados y como estos casos hay
miles y miles repartidos por todo el
mundo y esto lógicamente ha hecho que la
Iglesia Católica pues gane mucha
simpatía entre los más vulnerables Y por
supuesto también entre los propios
estados donde presta su ayuda y eso no
es todo luego Además está también la
capacidad de mediación que tiene la
santa sede por ejemplo Juan Pablo II me
dio entre Argentina y chile para evitar
una guerra inminente por la soberanía de
las islas del canal de beagle o sin ir
más lejos el Papa Francisco medio entre
Obama y Raúl Castro para relajar las
tensiones entre Washington y la Habana y
lograr Así que ambos gobiernos liberaran
algunos presos que tenían del otro país
y luego están las campañas
porque la santa sede participa también
en muchísimas campañas políticas a nivel
internacional por ejemplo para reclamar
la libertad de culto contra la pobreza y
ahora con el Papa Francisco están
metidos de lleno en la lucha contra el
cambio climático será cosa de los
tiempos pero sin duda Hay un mensaje del
Papa Francisco que ha hecho que la
simpatía por él especialmente en el
mundo desarrollado se haya disparado
atentos
de la República democrática
basta sofocar el África
de África no es una niñera de un solo
llave África hacía protagonista del Sur
del destino Exacto queridos amigos
amigas a todos los reclamos del Papa
Francisco contra el consumismo y por la
lucha contra el cambio climático ahora
también se suma un discurso claramente
anticolonial fijaos
colonialismo económico ante tantos que
habitantes
[Música]
ahora bien y si os dijera que estas
palabras No son casuales que esta puede
ser la mejor baza para el futuro de la
Iglesia Católica sorprendidos pues
prestad mucha pero que mucha atención
[Música]
el nuevo Hub religioso del catolicismo
vale al comienzo de este vídeo ya hemos
dicho que hay una especie de sensación
general de que la iglesia católica no
atraviesa sus mejores momentos que está
de capa caída vaya y desde luego lo que
nos dicen los datos es exactamente que
eso es lo que está ocurriendo en Europa
ya os hemos contado como el viejo
continente pues hace tiempo que dejó de
ser la región con el mayor número de
católicos de hecho os hago una pregunta
sabréis decirme Cuál es la región con
mayor población católica de todo el
mundo no no se trata de África sino de
América Latina un 28% de los 1.360
millones de católicos que hay en el
planeta viven Precisamente en esta
región hablamos por tanto de unas 380
millones de personas y pensadlo bien
teniendo en cuenta su pasado colonial
bajo el Imperio español pues no resulta
nada raro que así sea pero Y si os
dijera que el catolicismo se ha
estancado en América Latina y si os
dijera que hoy por hoy la Iglesia
Católica tiene puesta toda su atención
en África y os preguntaréis en África
por qué pues muy simple las tasas de
crecimiento de población católica en
África son muy superiores a las de
América Latina y por supuesto también a
las de Europa Y a qué se debe este
crecimiento Pues a lo que ya os hemos
contado antes a la labor social que
lleva a cabo la Iglesia Católica en el
Continente tanto construyendo las
escuelas que os hemos dicho en burkina
faso en Kenia como hospitales y
programas de ayuda para los más
desfavorecidos ahora bien o momento
pensar que este crecimiento se debe
única y exclusivamente a los logros de
la Iglesia Católica en el África
subsahariana sería un tremendo error hay
otro factor un factor absolutamente
decisivo y la expansión del catolicismo
en esta región tenéis alguna idea de
cuál puede ser 321 Exacto el crecimiento
demográfico
como podéis ver desde 1960 la población
en el continente africano no ha parado
de crecer desde unos escasos 250
millones de habitantes a más de 1.300
millones en la actualidad y ojo Porque
esa tendencia no va a cambiar la tasa de
fertilidad en África supera los cuatro
nacimientos por mujer por eso la ONU
nuevo tiene muy pero que muy claro para
el año 2050 África tendrá más de 2.400
millones de habitantes lo que supondrá
algo así como el 25% de toda la
población mundial os dais cuenta de lo
que esto puede suponer para la santa
sede os dais cuenta de que esto puede
conllevar una enorme expansión del
catolicismo desde luego las proyecciones
sobre el aumento de la población
cristiana en el Continente estoy seguro
absolutamente seguro de que emocionan al
Papa Francisco fijaos y hablamos de sólo
cinco países según el pury el número de
cristianos se doblarán países como
Nigeria y se triplicará en países como
tanzania estos cinco países estarán
entre los 10 países con más población
cristiana de todo el mundo y por
supuesto en ellos la religión cristiana
dominante será el catolicismo En otras
palabras que entre el aumento de la
población en África y su constante
presencia en esta región que es muy
posible que la Iglesia Católica llegue a
ser más grande de lo que nunca jamás ha
sido así que eso de que está de capa
caída pues como que no
esperanza del mundo
el representante Claro en acción
sorprendidos ya veis que a veces las
cosas no son lo que parecen ahora bien
la santa sede parece tenerlo todo a su
favor para dominar el panorama religioso
del continente africano pero creéis que
no va a tener oposición Pues como ya os
podéis imaginar nada más lejos de la
realidad
[Música]
musulmana y demonios internos
como en toda lucha por el poder o la
influencia siempre que hay un actor
emergente también hay competencia y este
es justo el caso de la santa sede en
África ya que tienen frente a la
religión con más fieles de todo el mundo
el islam por suerte los tiempos de las
cruzadas Ya quedaron atrás Así que no
esperéis ninguna Guerra sin cuartel por
el control de la fe sin embargo la
Iglesia Católica sí que va a tener que
enfrentarse a un islam que está muy
arraigado en gran parte del continente
que también espera expandirse y que
puede contar con varias ventajas amigos
amigas el Isla misma religión más
procesada del mundo y también la segunda
más profesada de África con casi 600
millones de musulmanes de esta forma tal
y como ocurre con el catolicismo en el
África subsahariana el islam también
está consiguiendo avanzar en esta región
desde el norte de África que es
abrumadoramente musulmán bien en este
caso la vertiente del Isla más
practicada en el continente es el
sufismo ya os hemos hablado en este
canal de esta rama del islam una rama
que se centra en la vida espiritual y en
la búsqueda de una relación más Mística
con la desde un prisma mucho más
individual sin embargo lo cierto es que
el sufismo ha estado perdiendo terreno
durante el siglo 21 a manos de la
versión más radical del islam el
salafismo Y si recordáis bien pues
defiende La pureza de la doctrina
religiosa y la textualidad del coral la
suna la yihad y la gran mayoría de
hadices que son los mensajes que se
atribuyen a Mahoma y que ordenan muchos
aspectos de la vida Los salafistas
rechazan frontalmente al resto de
religiones e incluso al resto de
vertientes del propio islam como es el
caso del propio sufismo
y desde luego esto supone un gran reto
para la iglesia católica no tanto por la
vertiente sufí con la que tiene una
batalla más bien teológica y argumental
para conseguir más adeptos sino sobre
todo por la vertientes a la vista una
rama del islam que nos deja noticias
como esta Nigeria sospecha que el estado
islámico mató a 40 personas en una
iglesia católica cristianos de burkina
faso asesinados en un ataque a una
iglesia terrible Claro que los problemas
no solo vienen desde fuera iglesia
católica también tiene que tener cuidado
con una vertiente mucho más ortodoxa y
conservadora del catolicismo una
vertiente cuyas raíces son muy pero que
muy profundas en África algunos de esos
máximos exponentes son por ejemplo el
cardenal guineano Robert Sara que ha
llegado aquí con cualquier cosa que
pueda sonar a ideología de género al
menos en su cabeza O también es el caso
de Peter coduo que llegó aquí parar a
los homosexuales con los pedófilos de
locos de hecho esta posición
abiertamente contraria a las personas
lgtbi ya se ha trasladado recientemente
a la política y a la legislación en un
país de mayoría católica como es Wanda
fijaos ni contra la homosexualidad en
uganda cadena perpetua por decir que
eres gay y claro estas posturas pues
chocan de manera frontal con las nuevas
tendencias que está marcando el Papa
Francisco de la santa sede Papa
Francisco dice que leyes que
criminalizan a las personas lgbt son un
pecado y una injusticia como podéis ver
la santa sede se enfrenta tanto a una
oposición exterior que en algunos casos
es muy pero que muy radical y
tremendamente violenta como la de los
salafistas como también a una iglesia
católica africana mucho más ortodoxa que
la de Roma lo que hace improbable que
vayamos a ver al menos por el momento Un
poco africano
Pero lo que sí es indudable que veremos
es la creciente influencia de la
comunidad católica africana en el mundo
acompañado de un enorme crecimiento
demográfico el catolicismo sigue
creciendo allí como en ningún otro lugar
del planeta por eso aunque en Europa
esté perdiendo terreno frente al
leicismo de los estados y al creciente
ateísmo social sobre todo entre las
nuevas generaciones en África la santa
sede está encontrando su nuevo espacio
protagonista Así que no no es Sensato
decir que la Iglesia Católica está de
capa caída simplemente está reoriendose
y es muy posible que dentro de unos años
veamos una iglesia católica más fuerte y
más grande que nunca una iglesia además
en franca expansión pero llegados hasta
aquí la pregunta es para todos vosotros
creéis que África se convertirá
finalmente en el centro del catolicismo
mundial tal y como aparecen pronosticar
los datos veis posible un Renacer del
catolicismo en Europa o una reactivación
en América del Sur cuida acaso la lucha
entre el catolicismo y el islam en
África tener consecuencias más graves
llegaremos a ver alguna vez a un papá
africano podéis dejarme como siempre
vuestras respuestas en los comentarios y
si este vídeo os ha resultado
interesante no olvidéis darle al botón
de like y suscribiros al poli tik si es
que aún no lo habéis hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]